the el-fish loom roundabout is in the
heart of tripoli on most days during the
year hundreds of african laborers can be
found here looking for work
but during the holy month of ramadan
things slow down and the crowds thin
abdul rahim is a painter from niger he
says he came to libya two years ago to
find work and provide for his family
back home
during ramadan work is hard to come by
many of us don't make enough money to be
able to buy food i have friends who
haven't eaten for days but some people
do try to help
the un says there are more than 610
000 migrants in libya it's long been a
transit hub for african migrants trying
to reach europe the international
organization for migration says at least
660 people died risking the dangerous
journey in the mediterranean
sea
and nearly 900 are missing some migrants
such as sophian from sudan are not
interested in going to europe
they seek economic opportunities in
libya
some of us have family members who are
sick and need to make money for their
treatment there is little work during
ramadan it's hard for us i need to work
so i can eat and send money to my family
ramadan is the holiest month for muslims
they fast from sunrise until sunset and
believe it's a time for giving an act of
charity
many migrants depend on the goodwill of
libyans such as hamid al-dibh who
started the farikh san charity
organization seven years ago
during ramadan labourers don't find work
so we try to help them and give them
food it's our obligation as muslims to
help those in need
libya has been engulfed in conflict and
political divisions for more than a
decade
but migrants still risk coming here
because there are no job opportunities
at home
although difficult
and at times dangerous for some it's
their only hope to provide for
themselves and their families malik
trainer al jazeera tripoli